because our politics have really
descended into this gutter of place of
like it's just like a disgusting bar
fight of drunkenness and this next guest
i would consider an expert on those
things because he's a philly sports fan
you know a thing or two about drunk
fights host of waters world co-host of
the five jesse waters is here
how you doing jimmy good good and could
you confirm from my listeners because we
talk a lot about philly sports fans on
this show
they're a pretty hard scrabble bunch but
they live up to the stereotype in a good
way they're passionate they care
so i took my wife to an eagles game
she'd never been there before it was a
playoff game
and she accidentally wore a purple
pullover
and we happened to be playing the
minnesota vikings
we get out of that car and they just
descended on this poor girl
like taunting they threw a beer at her
yeah we hadn't even gotten inside the
stadium
so she had to take the pull over off and
underneath she had a white cut off tank
top which was even worse
it attracted even more attention but the
wrong kind as well
so they're just barbaric and we love
them for that well i love them because
what philly fans are to me is they're
what yankee fans used to be
before they priced the character out of
the stadium how much is a beer there now
that's what it is
nobody eighteen dollars no one throws
beer it's 18 you're not throwing a beer
it's like lumber you show up in a red
sock jersey you'll get hit with an ipad
mini
maybe an engagement ring they're not
throwing beer at uh but jesse is here
he's got a fantastic new book out
called how i save the world and i mean
this it was helpful
it was i i read like like grown up i
read it cover to cover
i had real questions but there was one
point you made earlier that i make a lot
on this show
that i think um people would be
surprised to hear coming from you
but in a roundabout way you're kind of
rooting for the democratic party to
regain its
you called it it's rigor you said
they've lost their rigour yeah they
don't care for substantive debate
they're more consumed with character
assassination which to be fair
you do a lot of character assassinating
in the book most of it is your own yes i
found it
yes i committed suicide in this book
i call it a confessional because i
really poured my heart out and that's
what i wanted to do well listen you did
this right because if you're writing a
screenplay
people want to see vulnerability out of
the hero like they like to see clintus
would get beat up before he kills
everybody at the end
and uh there were some moments there was
some uh i guess your parents sent you to
a lot of summer camps yes
yes survival camps not a summer camp
i've been to a summer camp you probably
have too that's where
there's a cabin yeah and there's lunch
somebody's a revival
they gave you a knife and a book of
matches and said i'll see you in 10 days
but i thought that was great and i did
love that you failed one of the camps
because apparently the actual critique
i did the actual critique was that and i
don't know if anybody would deduce this
from watching jesse on tv but
the claim was that you were more
concerned with your suntan than rock
climbing they said i put people's lives
in danger
that was a quote because i didn't i
didn't correctly learn all of the
sophisticated
ropes and ties and knots thank you but i
listen i wouldn't have either and
and i feel like on some level this is
what i was going to ask you
because you went to a lot of these camps
are they just trying to get rid of you
what are you that was a part of it is
that what it was that was a part of it
because you know in the summer time do
you really want to put up with some
annoying 16 year old kid
no you want to send them as far away as
possible for as long as possible
so the camps kept getting longer and
more dangerous so like the first summer
in like seventh grade
it was a week then it was two weeks then
it was a month and it was two months
and by the end it was like you know
you know when women just go hiking by
themselves and they have to send a
helicopter
that's the kind of camp this was scary
you could tell how your parents feel
about you yes jesse we got this nice
summer camp at the gaza strip
you're going to love it bring someone
and that's how it felt like in some of
these camps because you know at first it
was like a bunch of preppy white kids
and then it was kids with like kids were
taking medication because of their
bipolarity
kids were showing up in like a taxi with
like a glad
bag with their gear in it like dangerous
fellas
criminal criminal element at the jesse
water summit yes jesse waters of the
studio if you're just joining us um you
did say in the book which i found
interesting
that at trinity college in hartford was
where you had your political awakening
i got drunk and woke up in my dorm room
and i was watching c-span i don't think
i'd ever turned to c-span but i was
listening to the republican senator's
pontificate on the floor
about whatever policy they were talking
about and
their philosophy just jived with the
founders about limited government so
that's when it
stuck and then i turned limbaugh and
once you turn limbaugh on
rush baby yeah and i used to force my
parents to listen to limbaugh
on long car rides and it would cause
road rage like my mom
i think almost rear-ended a a pickup
truck after a welfare reform monologue
she was that angry but i but i liked the
fact that he was making my parents angry
i felt like he was saying the right
things like if he could make my parents
angry this guy's great he's your punk
rock he's right it was rebellious
i believe if you look at accident
reports across the country from 1988 to
2017 the word feminazi is listed
in like 200 000 accident reports no he
had a way of getting it done but i
i actually i was gonna ask you this
because you had a political awakening at
college but you didn't show up to
college like hell bent on protesting
are you on some level fascinated by how
grievance oriented college kids are
because like i never worried in college
about
protesting i'm worried about running out
of beer you probably worried about
running out of beer
so i said in the book i i didn't go to
college to protest i went there to party
yeah my college trinity college in
2000 there was i don't even think there
was a college democrat club
i i didn't i never saw a protest
everybody got along the black students
got along with the white students
everything was chill but now you go on
college campus and it's apartheid
white privilege you know people are
boycotting the cafeteria
i i don't get it that college is such a
special opportunity
you learn whatever you want you get to
meet girls you get to play sports
you can even make your classes they
don't even class doesn't even have to
start until noon yeah sometimes
so take advantage of that i know you
have plenty of time after college to get
angry and progressive
i see i agree with you i think they're
wasting such an opportunity for fun
learn something have some fun let's not
get nuts
yeah yeah but you don't have to pay any
bills but i have to get that seriously
but have some fun
um something you talked about in the
book that i enjoyed is you talked about
how
you reduce the value of risk uh or the
potential of risk as you get older
that's why i don't
tweet that's what you're talking about
it's like when you were 18 you would
have jumped out of a plane
with a parachute right right because
that was an adrenaline rush would i do
that now
at 42 and 43 with children
with an investment account you know with
property no
you never want to do that and that's why
i don't tweet because if i say the wrong
thing do i need any more scandal
opportunities no no
i've had enough of that well i was going
to say this to you because you
acknowledged it you said as
as juicy as my cancellation would be you
have to be considered in the pantheon of
cancel like cancellations you've got to
be top three in the country
it would be orgasmic for me to be
cancelled
on the left i mean we're talking as as
they felt
maybe i wouldn't con compare myself to
trump but when trump got knocked off
social media they would love to see me
knocked off oh man like juicy
did i just compare myself to trump i
don't think i really meant that but i
would that would be trumpy and to do but
it would be it would be very trumpian
to exaggerate one stature yes you know
that would be uh good well there's a
great if everybody listening to this
um is listening you know half of them
are listening because they hate you
because of your politics they should
know that if they read this book there
would be so many better reasons to hate
you
so people you know when you hate watch a
television show people should hate read
this book yes
someone wrote a review on amazon if you
love jesse you'll love this book if you
hate jesse you'll love this oh it's so
it's right there it's right there but
the best stories
that i that i really took from you talk
about some life experiences where you
were a bellman at the omni hotel in
philly
uh striking out with women but it's such
a good story because i forgot i was
wearing a bellman uniform
so i would i would i would always
beeline for the babes to take their
luggage upstairs and i'd take it
upstairs and i'd deliver the bags
and i'd linger in the doorway like i had
a shot
and i'd say with my khaki bellhop
uniform with the nametag i'd say
is there anything else and jimmy there
was
never anything else ever
it was the washington generals of
hookups they lost to the harlem
globetrotters every time
i was i was winless but people will
appreciate the humility of that because
i can tell you someone who drove a cab a
long time
the same thing you sometimes have this
blinder of entitlement like you think
you're eligible in a competition
right that you haven't been registered
in this karate tournament right miyagi
didn't fill out there
they are looking at the back of your
head and they can't wait
to get to that drop-off location
that's so true but it was great jesse
waters is in studio
uh we got i just wanna i wanna just give
jimmy a shout out because i think he may
have been one of the only people that
interviewed me about the book who
actually read the book okay no we've had
a lot of great people interviewing me
but you actually have read the book i
don't know is this the first book you've
read
stop it i mean if you've heard the show
it might be the only you know
no i'm big into pop-ups and you know i
read the biden memoir it was a scratch
and sniff
it was a lot going on thank you for
reading the book no i enjoyed it i mean
one thing i can tell you is i wrote a
book based on the time i spent driving a
cab and i had the same experience as you
i knew people were just talking to me
about the book it's a humbling
experience yeah it is and it's good for
people to be humbled do you kind of feel
like i was going to ask you this when
you're in the process
of writing a book don't you almost feel
like a unibomber and that you're so
sequestered off with your thoughts for
such a large amount of time i write that
at the end
i said jesse waters has actually gotten
sick
of talking about jessie waters i didn't
think i could get sick of it but i did
and you know after a while it's enough
with the self-introspection
yeah you just gotta stop looking inside
and you start
gotta start pointing fingers at other
people and that's where i am now
no this this book ends with him throwing
a lot of rocks out of that glass house
so i'm just hurling rocks at passerby
let me ask you a couple of waters things
though so a little more
self-introspection
one of the cool stories in the book is
about how the first time you pitched to
bill o'reilly
he thought you were an intern uh and you
had the experience of being in front of
what you described as like simon cowell
yeah that's good you pitched bad you got
shot down
without even i write that did i say he
was the simon cowell yeah it was like a
simon county good line yes
i keep re-reading the book for the first
time and i was like oh that was a good
line well this is
it no it's solid it's solid i wish you'd
compliment your looks a little more
though
enough of that read the book um but
let's talk about this
how are you as the recipient of pitches
as a guy who hosts his own show
are you agreeable or are you like how do
you how does your staff handle you
so all of our pitches now on waters
world are
digital communications we used to do the
in-person
pitch meeting and i found them tedious
and insufferable
and i think that's how my staff saw me
as tedious and insufferable
so we just knocked that off and they
just emailed me now oh that's funny well
that's no it's good insight into the
process it's efficient is what you're
trying to say
so as a producer who's now a host
it's tough because i know what it takes
to produce a show
so i have very little patience for
mistakes and i know
we shouldn't be leaving things to the
last minute you know i didn't want this
interview to become something where i
trashed my staff no you stand i'm not
trashing my staff but i have high
standards because you know i i know what
it takes to put on a cable show no i
agree 100
um let me ask you this though papa
waters is the original uh
collar popper in the family yes so dad
my father
popped his collar as his father had
popped his before him
um and so i didn't think there was
anything that strange about it
yeah so one of the times i went out on
one of these factor shoots
and it was hot so i popped it and it
kind of gave me a little flair
to separate myself from the rest of the
games that walk around with a mic
and bill said now orders now that you've
done it once
you can't put it down it's now your
trademark
so no matter what color i wore i had to
put it up that's funny yeah your dad
popped a collar my dad popped a cannon
meister braille
every day at three his father popped the
cannon meister brown
long line of descendants uh last
question then um
you said the pandemic humbled you by the
end because you were home and stuff
and i know you've kind of come out of
that awakening now but do you think on
some level this is my theory anyway
i feel like everybody was forced to
reevaluate everything in the course of
the last year because the destruction
around everybody was so arbitrary at
times that i do feel like everyone went
through this like thorough self-vetting
process where they're kind of
relaunching
life did you take anything out of that
that's different now
i know that's kind of heavy for the for
the end well i did write the book during
the pandemic yeah which was
it forced me to really get cracking
because there was nowhere else to go
yeah you have no excuse no excuses
yeah that's a great point like if all of
those people if they didn't catch up
with you last year
they're not your friends they're not
there's no excuse for not having caught
up in the last year
right so you know i think what remains
important and was important before but
people didn't realize it family is
important
and friends are important but just
getting on a schedule
and staying disciplined with your
exercise cooking for yourself that's a
lost art i know
and and and if you like your spouse
the pandemic was amazing yeah you're
like you hit the lottery but if you
hated your spouse
that was torture yeah and everybody
knows what i'm talking about no
you're spot on it's like nobody nobody
whenever you hear stories with
very few exceptions with very few
exceptions nobody you hear that's having
a baby post lockdown is having a third
or a fourth
they're usually having a first because
nobody who homeschooled was like
we should do more of this you know what
i mean no it got it got dicey like you
know things were bad if you got kicked
out of a zoom cocktail party
yeah like all right this guy yeah we
can't even have this guy in a microphone
right uh but
i did not ever participate in that but
i'm sure you did there were moments i'm
not proud we lost a lot of good men out
there
uh the book is called how i save the
world and uh if you didn't pull it off
you came perilously close it was a photo
finish thank you it's great has anybody
ever said that this office
of yours looks like the 40 year old
virgin's
apartment has anybody said that about
listen i'm glad you did this
am i the first one no it does what it
looks like for real though
it does it looks like the inside of a
van that promised you candy
you know can you even imagine in that
data hey kid get in the van i got candy
they're like does it contain peanuts yes
it's it's a whole different game now but
it's a fantastic book you should check
it out
jesse waters thanks for this man